Have you ever sympathized with a monster?
I remember as a child seeing images depicting
the legend of Saint George slaying a dragon.
But I didn’t have the reaction to these
pictures I was supposed to.
The dragons didn’t look evil.
They looked sad.
And the older I’ve become, the more media
I’ve seen where monsters suffer…
the less monstrous they seem.
(Sympathy for the Monster)
To empathize with a monster is to go against thousands of years of storytelling precedent.
The traditional mythic role of a monster is
to be a kind of living obstacle, typically
one that embodies dominant fears in its culture
of origin.
The very word ‘Monster’ comes from the
Latin ‘monere,’ meaning ‘to warn.’
When a courageous hero vanquishes a monster,
it’s not supposed to be tragic, but a victory
over a societal anxiety.
This conventional model of monster-hood is
one most of us are familiar with.
Next to — pottery, maybe?
— monsters are about as close to a cultural
universal as you can get.
Wherever there are people telling stories,
there are stories of monsters.
But what is considered monstrous and worthy
of scorn or fear varies across cultures and
time.
So, what one civilization judges to be irredeemable,
another might pity and empathize with.
It all comes down to perspective.
Like, there’s that one scene in Star Wars
where our hero crushes a monster called a
Rancor with a gate, which feels triumphant,
until you see this one side character looks
so heartbroken, like this creature meant the
world to him.
And though the Rancor didn’t seem like the…
nicest fellow, as a child this moment made
me wonder if the creature was truly evil,
or just a starving animal in a pit.
Sympathizing with a monster isn’t a novel
concept, but it is one that’s evolved over
the years.
One of the most important turning points in
film came in the early 20th century when Universal
Pictures thrust the tragic monster into the
Hollywood zeitgeist with the success of the
1931’s Frankenstein.
Based on Mary Shelly’s 19th century novel
about scientist Victor Frankenstein who animates
a creature made from corpses, the film makes
numerous changes to the source material, yet
keeps the core tragedy of the central unwanted
creation.
Upon awakening, Frankenstein’s monster is
essentially an innocent newborn, but because
of his monstrous strength and appearance,
he’s abandoned and mistreated by those around
him — including his own creator.
It is through this mistreatment that the monster
learns to act monstrous, lashing out with
anger at a world that has given him anger
in turn.
And the film emphasizes that the creature
does have the capacity for kindness if met
with kindness, even if just for a fleeting
moment.
Though he cannot help being inhuman in the
eyes of others, his nature is not inherently
inhumane.
Where the novel and the film differ is that
in the movie, the creature remains infantile
until the end, whereas in the book he becomes
eloquent and cunning, committing inhumane
acts with full awareness to punish his creator.
Yet the novel, too, indicates that the creature’s
cruelty stems from its initial abandonment,
and the horror that follows is ultimately
the fault of Dr. Frankenstein’s hubris.
The very idea for the creature came from Mary
Shelly’s apprehension towards people attempting
to use electricity to revive corpses.
So, while Frankenstein’s monster embodies
fears of human recklessness, he is also, innately,
a victim of that same recklessness.
There’s the old ‘gotcha’ that “Frankenstein
isn’t the name of the monster, but the name
of the man.”
But from a thematic perspective, it’s not
that clear cut…
Yet Frankenstein wasn’t the only 19th-century-monster-novel-turned-blockbuster
to come out in 1931.
Universal’s Dracula was an even bigger hit
— sticking more closely to a folkloric model
of monster-hood, with a largely unsympathetic
monster threatening the sanctity of a social
good.
This Dracula can be seen as a manifestation
of U.S. postwar anxieties over perceived external
dangers coming from afar to threaten the home,
as can many of the Universal creature-features
that followed.
Yet a surprising number of these films also
find pathos in their monsters, with the writers
aware, at least on some level, of the tragedy
inherent in being rejected by society for
something you can’t control.
So maybe it’s no surprise that many of these
monsters have been reimagined over the years
as more sympathetic and non-threatening figures.
Asking audiences to empathize with, say, a
vampire, is far from unheard of these days.
“It opened its wings like this, screeching,
now you are vampire!
…And it was Peter.
And we are still friends today.”
The surprisingly sympathetic framing of Universal’s
early monsters can in many ways be traced
back to the 1928 silent film The Man Who Laughs.
The story of a circus performer mutilated
as a child into having a permanent grin, the
central figure in The Man Who Laughs is neither
a supernatural creature, nor in any way villainous.
He is only a ‘monster’ from the perspective
of a public that will not accept him.
Though likely the inspiration for the iconic
villain the Joker, the original man who laughs
never snaps and becomes the monster everyone
expects him to be.
In fact, he gets a happy ending despite his
appearance never changing.
For a movie from the 1920s, the film is surprisingly
nuanced in its exploration of the lead character’s
lived experience.
At the time of release, the man who laughs
was lumped with figures like the Hunchback
of Notre Dame by marketers under the umbrella
of ‘Universal Monsters’ — which speaks
to a callous public perception of people that
were physically non-normative.
This tragically echoes the history of many
so-called monsters in folklore, with werewolf
legends, for example, likely related to individuals
with hypertrichosis — a condition that causes
hair growth throughout the body.
Fear of the unknown or of that which a social
majority deems abnormal is at the heart of
a lot of monster myths, with the label of
‘monster’ used to demonize and dehumanize
those perceived as ‘other.’
In European history, fear of the unknown also
manifested in the form of ‘geographic monsters’
— the kinds of beasts that populate the
edges of Medieval and Renaissance maps, meant
to invoke the perceived dangers of far-off
locations.
Over the centuries, tall-tales of fantastical
beings from distant lands and distorted accounts
of actual wildlife combined with growing Imperialism
into a worldview that linked monsters with
regions unmapped by Europeans.
By the early 20th century, this worldview
merged with paleontological discoveries to
create ‘Lost World’ narratives, wherein
adventurers would discover not mythic monsters
but lost prehistoric life — which they then
‘conquered’ in a manner that reflected
imperialist attitudes towards nature and indigenous
populations.
And out of this muddled mythos emerged King
Kong — one of the more enduring pop-culture
figures of the last century, with a complex
place in the realm of sympathetic monster-dom.
Coming two years after Universal’s monsters
broke onto the scene, the original King Kong
is a movie of contrasts.
On the one hand, the titular Kong feels like
the geographic monster personified — presented
as a treacherous embodiment of the unknown
that the intrepid explorers must subjugate.
On the other hand, unlike most Universal monsters,
Kong is — at least initially — not the
invading figure, but the one attacked in his
own home.
And the film does seem aware of and sympathetic
to this unfairness on some level.
Not just an obstacle, Kong is given moments
that could be classified as heroic — which
later reboots have made more explicitly valiant.
Though Kong eventually rampages through New
York, this only occurs after he is forcibly
removed from his original environment.
And here the film’s sympathies split once
again, as Kong’s eventual fate at the hands
of the military is presented as both tragic…
and the preordained outcome of nature clashing
with industrial society.
Peter Jackson’s reboot in particular brings
this tragedy more to the surface, but in that
film, Kong’s defeat upon challenging humanity
still seems inescapable.
Which is why it’s notable that the latest
incarnation of Kong flips this dynamic on
its head.
In that series, Kong is closer to a deity
— a symbolic reminder of how insignificant
humanity is compared to the endurance of the
natural world.
This is also the most overtly noble version
of Kong ever put to film: presented as an
honorable defender of the ecosystem.
The original movie might pity Kong to an extent,
but the latest incarnation is explicitly,
textually on the side of Kong and not the
humans pillaging his home.
He is always the invaded — never the invader.
And I think this transformation means more
than critics give it credit for.
The fact that Kong has gone from semi-antagonist
to… essentially an action hero, suggests
that the attitude of general audiences towards
monsters has changed over the last century.
Speaking of which, isn’t there another iconic
giant monster who’s gone from villain to
hero over the decades?
Godzilla rose up from the depths in the early
50s, ushering in a new wave of atomic age
monsters.
Anxiety over the seemingly limitless potential
of nuclear power led to a slew of films where
unfeeling mutants terrorized humanity for
their folly.
Though many were the creation of Hollywood,
Godzilla was a uniquely Japanese depiction
of post-nuclear trauma, with the first film
a somber analogue for atomic devastation.
But the more Godzilla films came out, the
more the tone, uh, shifted a little bit — with
the movies becoming increasingly silly.
No longer a dead-serious embodiment of postwar
suffering, Godzilla became something of a
national mascot — a figure who, though occasionally
still destructive, was typically contrasted
against a more overtly villainous monster.
This change was in response to Japanese audiences
sympathizing with the character, and wanting
to see him as the protagonist, despite his
monstrous form.
The director of the original Godzilla, Ishirō
Honda, has a poignant quote on this, stating:
“Monsters are tragic beings.
They are born too tall, too strong, too heavy…
They are not evil by choice.
That is their tragedy.”
Over the decades, Godzilla’s villainy would
wax and wane through different incarnations
— but one of the most important incarnations
came recently in the film Shin Godzilla.
This movie, in many respects, returns Godzilla
to his roots as a personification of wartime
destruction.
It’s probably the most nightmarish version
of Godzilla seen onscreen thus far, a borderline
eldritch being who brings only devastation.
But hidden within the narrative is a highly
sympathetic portrait of an animal in a state
of suffering.
Godzilla begins the film in apparent agony
— a mutant newly created from nuclear waste
barely able to stand.
And no matter how destructive he becomes,
there’s always a sense this is a creature
in terrible pain.
During the final rampage, ominous operatic
music plays, but if you listen to the lyrics,
it seems like a plea from Godzilla’s perspective,
lamenting that no one understands its sorrow.
“If I die in this world, / Who will know
something of me?
/ …A downward slope / Is all I see.”
Shin Godzilla isn’t about to save the world
with a majestic dropkick, yet the film argues
this veritable god of ruin deserves your sympathy
as well.
Like Mary Shelly’s monster, he is a victim
of humanity’s hubris, a monster who never
asked to be made.
Conversely, a heroic modern interpretation
of the character comes from the Legendary
films, wherein Godzilla is not a mutant, but
a preexisting superorganism from the Permian
Period that nuclear testing happened to awaken.
This changes the character into more of a
force of nature rather than manmade calamity.
Much like the latest version of Kong, Godzilla
is presented as a guardian of ecological stability
— in fact, those two incarnations of the
characters share continuity.
A curious byproduct of this reimagining, however,
is that like earlier films that framed Godzilla
as the protagonist, these monsters now have
‘monsters’ of their own — unsympathetic
living obstacles that must be put down to
protect a greater good.
Typically, these villains take the form of
outside threats to the ecosystem — most
traditionally, aliens.
Aliens rose to prominence in Hollywood in
the late fifties and early sixties, stealing
the crown from nuclear mutants as the dominant
pop-culture monsters.
So, the fact that the earliest Godzilla films
to frame him as a hero put him up against
aliens is appropriate — turning him into
the reigning champion of monster-hood defending
the throne from new upstarts.
In the U.S. especially, the alien craze reflected
Cold War fears of invasion — the extraterrestrials
portrayed as infiltrators with secretly deviant
appearances and agendas.
Aliens might not seem like they belong to
the monster category, but though cloaked in
the scientific jargon of the space age, most
mid-20th century extraterrestrials were still
archetypal boogeymen — manifestations of
cultural paranoia that needed to be vanquished.
Not all aliens to come out of this era were
malicious.
But aliens that could be trusted typically
looked like Spock, while anything nonhumanoid
was more likely to be duplicitous.
This is a trend that’s continued…
pretty much until the modern day.
There’s ET, of course, but he’s something
of an outlier.
Notable recent works that break from this
framing include District 9 and Arrival.
The design of the aliens in these films fall
in line with the bug or squid-like aliens
that terrorized the B-movie of the 50s and
60s, yet neither of these non-human aliens
are depicted as villainous.
In fact, the central conflict of both films
stems not from the aliens possessing secret
plans to invade, but from humanity’s fearful
reaction to a perceived threat.
As was often true in the McCarthy era, the
only monsters in these films are the ones
people invent — and the ones they become
in the name of destroying the imagined interlopers.
A sympathetic monster who exists at the crossroads
of all these themes is the Gill Man from Universal’s
The Creature from the Black Lagoon.
First appearing in the 50s, the Gill Man was
a monster dislodged from time, both in the
narrative, and in era the film was released.
Though marketed as a sci-fi creation, the
Gill Man fit more with the then out-of-style
geographic monster of King Kong’s era.
And as was the case with Kong, the portrayal
of the Gill Man is a complicated one.
He is easily the least aggressive of the classic
Universal monsters, beginning the film as
more curious and only resorting to violence
after being attacked multiple times — and
in his own home no less.
As film director Guillermo Del Toro puts it,
“He gets his home invaded and then roughed
around, you know?
…He was at home, swimming, and these guys
barge in.”
Yet the film itself doesn’t fully break
from the Imperialist model of monster-hood,
with the defeat of the Gill Man framed as
largely triumphant.
This questionable framing is the reason why
Del Toro’s chose the Gill Man as the inspiration
for the creature in The Shape of Water.
Set in Baltimore in the 1960s, the film subverts
the classical monster narrative by making
the fish man… basically the secondary protagonist
— using his plight as a means of exploring
the systemic inequality endemic to the era.
The Shape of Water makes overt what’s been
true for monster-media since its inception
— that portrayals of monsters often mirror
portrayals of marginalized groups.
Leading out of the late 60s, pop-culture monsters
would become increasingly decentralized as
film genres became more diverse, with their
appearance and level of sympathy varying greatly.
One of the last widespread trends was the
horde of zombie-centric media that shambled
to the forefront of monster-dom in the 2010s.
Though the mindless zombie might feel purely
unsympathetic, the myth intertwines with an
older, particularly tragic form of monster-hood
we’ll call the ‘transformed monster.’
Stories like The Wolfman and Dr. Jekeil and
Mr. Hyde helped establish the trope of otherwise
innocent humans who transform into monsters
and lose control.
In their monster forms, these characters typically
cannot be reasoned with.
The sympathy comes from the audience knowing
who they were — and recognizing that this
is a fate they would never choose.
Mainstream zombies appeal to emotion in a
similar way.
Though the aggressive creatures have lost
their humanity, there is no escaping the fact
that each one used to be human.
Every zombie is the ending of a melancholy
tale, a fact that makes it difficult to completely
close your heart to them — even if they’re
just enemies in a video game.
Speaking of which, the most recent and perhaps
largest wave of sympathetic monsters can be
found in the medium of video games.
Traditionally, most games have stuck to the
mythic model of monster-hood, portraying them
as unfeeling enemies that the player must
overcome.
It’s a format that makes sense for interactivity
— games are all about obstacles, enemies
make for engaging obstacles, and monsters
are a clear visual shorthand for enemies.
And yet I think a lot of players can point
to at least one example of feeling bad for
a virtual monster.
The first time I encountered this feeling
was when I played Super Mario Galaxy as a
child.
Early on in this bright and colorful adventure,
you land on the egg of a giant monster that
hatches and turns aggressive.
You then have to defeat this newborn lifeform
in order to progress.
And it wasn’t until my first time beating
this boss that I realized how sad it is.
All this creature knows is violence — it’s
literally the first stimulus they ever experience.
I remember thinking that my actions created
this monster.
I’d just pulled a Frankenstein!
…Obviously that’s not what the developers
intended for young-me to take away from this
game.
In general, you aren’t supposed to see video
game monsters as thinking, feeling beings.
Which is why when a developer intentionally
subverts this trope, it can be so powerful.
The Dark Souls franchise is filled with tragic
enemies, almost everyone under some form of
heart-wrenching curse or another.
But easily the most effecting is Sif — a
giant wolf who wields a sword.
But while this monster might seem ridiculous,
the loyal canine is only trying to protect
the grave of its deceased owner.
And to make matters worse, there’s an alternate
route you can take where you bond with Sif
beforehand, and the wolf recognizes you before
you do battle.
It makes for an encounter that makes you reevaluate
your role in the story, and wish you could
choose to break from the cycle of monster
slaying.
In the game Skyrim… you actually can choose
to break from this cycle.
In this game, you play as a predestined hero
tasked with defeating a group of villainous
dragons, and you are rewarded mechanically
for slaying these creatures with useful upgrades.
For most of the game’s main story, this
conflict is pretty clear-cut — with the
dragons following the classical, Tolkien-style
model of unambiguous evil.
But this simplicity is upended when you meet
Paarthurnax, an elderly dragon who has reached
enlightenment through meditation and now avoids
conflict.
Part of what makes Paarthurnax so interesting
is he almost seems aware of his metatextual
role in the story.
He basically knows it’s his narrative destiny
to be monstrous, and yet he still refuses.
“What is better?
To be born good, or to overcome your evil
nature through great effort?”
And what’s heartbreaking is that you’re
nevertheless tasked with slaying this peaceful
being, and if you succeed, the game rewards
you with greater power.
But you can choose to never initiate this
fight, and if what I’ve read online is any
indication, most players don’t.
Even though the whole game is based around
fighting dragons, like Paarthurnax, people
seem able to step out of the narrative and
trust empathy over fear.
Fear is central to the player’s experience
in Shadow of the Colossus, the final game
I want to discuss in this video.
The game puts you up against some of the largest
monsters in the medium, creatures so worryingly
gigantic that all your panicked mind can think
of is how to survive.
While you might fear them, they certainly
don’t seem to fear you.
But everything changes when you make it to
the eleventh colossus.
Not only is this creature relatively tiny
compared to the other behemoths — it’s
scared of you.
Most video game enemies don’t show fear
— it’s an emotion that’s a little too
genuine, a little too human.
You defeat the eleventh colossus by wielding
a flaming torch to back it off the edge of
a cliff.
It’s a moment that, quite intentionally,
makes you question your heroic identity.
Because though it’s a cliché to say, from
this creature’s perspective…
the monster is you.
Humans and monsters have been inexorably intertwined
since our beginning.
In fact, you could argue humans used to live
in a world of monsters.
There used to be significantly more megafaunal
species that posed a threat to our ancestors.
It’s easy to imagine that life in such a
world would have been one of constant fear.
…But that’s not what you see in ancient
art of these lifeforms.
You see an incredible amount of care and reverence
for each creature — even ones that they’d
probably had violent encounters with.
Though it’s impossible to know the authorial
intent behind prehistoric paintings, when
I look at these portraits…
I feel like the artists were aware that these
creatures were alive like they were.
…I feel like they sympathized with them.
The main reason why I pitied dragons when
I was little… is because they seemed like
animals minding their own business until someone
invaded their habitat.
Indeed, many dragon myths likely stem from
interactions with then-unfamiliar and dangerous
animals.
But to my child self, these creatures didn’t
appear threatening — just misunderstood.
I felt that if someone took the time to document
their behavior, their fate could have been
avoided.
In a strange way, I think that’s part of
what set me on the road towards eventually
making this channel.
You can’t escape monsters.
They are culture and history, foundational
to how humans define the personhood of themselves
and others.
Though it’s easy to frame sympathy towards
them as a linear increase, the truth is monsters
are always changing, always representing a
new fear or new avenue for understanding.
This is actually my 100th Curious Archive
video, and almost every one has featured fictional
creatures to some extent.
Monsters aren’t ever going away.
But we can seek to understand them.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.